throughout human evolution eyes have
been vital to your survival we've
evolved to be round so that they can
swivel to spot delicious prey and easily
rule when your cousin talks about his
new car for the whole time but to get to
that point
our peoples have come a long way they
most lately developed from a tiny late
sense of patch on single-celled
organisms that would help them move
towards late and the hope of finding
food as the creatures evolved this patch
started to carve and want to better
focus lately and now a whole buncha
evolution layer what we've arrived at
are two twinkling spheres that are
capable of seeing about a million cars
nobody we may actually be one if
something without Wendell to the soul
stuff - as our eyes can portray more of
our emotions than you might think your
pupils dilate when you're scaled nervous
or excited that could be why they
enlarge when we make eye contact with
someone we like lately research has also
shown in the even making eye contact
with a portrait painting sets off a
whole raft of brain encode our eyes are
also responsible for another universal
emotional reaction a good old week but
we actually have three types of Tears
each with their own chemical makeup
basal which lubricate the eye reflex
tears caused by elephants like dust or
chopped onions and psychic or emotional
tears
the kind that appear when you find it a
bit Bambi's mom for the first me when it
comes to your pupils it's not just the
size of them that varies the shape of an
animal's pupils can tell us of its
predator or prey some have horizontal
pupils making them more adept at
scanning for prayer that azrael munching
on grass is found on your local goats
sheep and moose vertical pupils like
those phones and foxes cats and
crocodiles are better for ambition and
hunting at mate and have become
synonymous with animals that you just do
not wanna miss one around pupils are
kind of up based on both worlds and help
as an act of foraging and chasing down
three which you know we totally do ollie
there are quite a few animals who do a
better job of seein and we do the
elephant hawk moth which sounds like
that banjo badminton was the first
animal proven to be able to see color in
the dead of night the large sense of
eyes allow the maximum available light
to pass through however this does impact
their ability to detect fast-moving
objects like a rolled-up newspaper human
eyes may not be perfect parts of them
are even useless like that little pink
back and then a cornice is that a means
of a thump eyelid like the ones cats
dogs and camels have our eyes aren't
just physically interested but
culturally too much loved by conspiracy
theorists the world over the Eye of
Horus me symbolizes the illumina it is
some but its origins lie in Egypt where
the eye is a symbol representing
sacrifice healing and protection and
tokey some believed that sideways glance
can cause genuine pain and thinking back
to high school for no more glass
pendants also I shaped our warm to
protect against this evil life so
weather round monolith hooded don't ond
up Tom or almond words you're probably
familiar with if you spend as much time
watching makeup tutorials as me your
eyes are unique to you the tour even
unique to each other but one thing does
unit is all we can for the life of us
keep them all when we sneeze
[Music]
you
[Music]